y en qué consiste este llamado ciclón
bomba Y por qué las alertas
qué tal un gusto estar con ustedes Bueno
un bomba es una rápida identificación de
una tormenta es decir que el sistema de
bajas presiones tiene un descenso de 24
milibares en 24 horas y eso hace Por
supuesto que tenga como resultado las
fuertes Nevadas Los Fuertes vientos con
ráfagas que han superados las 100 millas
por hora acumulados de nieve que han
superado los dos pies de nieve y así que
las condiciones se mantienen muy
peligrosas a través de gran parte de
sectores de los grandes lagos de
nordeste del país donde además estas
condiciones de nieve de fuertes vientos
las temperaturas han descendido
muchísimo hemos hablado de sensaciones
térmicas que es lo que sentimos
realmente más allá que te termómetros
marcando valores en los negativos te
están sintiendo de temperaturas hasta en
menos sesenta grados Así que es un
notable descenso de la temperatura
también que pone en peligro a muchísimas
personas o cualquier ser vivo que se
encuentra al aire libre con ese con ese
descenso de las temperaturas de esa masa
de aire ártica acá invadido gran parte
del país bien entonces con ese panorama
para cuando se espera que mejoren las
condiciones y Cuáles son las
recomendaciones generales
las condiciones necesarias mejorar una
vez que pases a tu cuenta pero todavía
estaríamos viendo a pesar de que ya se
haya ido esas Nevadas o esos fuertes
vientos todavía quedarían Las bajas
temperaturas estamos hablando que
incluso al sur del país en la Florida
las temperaturas desciendan hasta los
cuarenta grados Así que estamos hablando
de un notable descenso las temperaturas
que en muchos años no habíamos visto por
ejemplo en Colorado no habíamos visto un
día tan frío en los últimos 32 años Así
que para que tenga una idea del notable
de centro de las temperaturas que
estamos hablando recomendaciones si no
tiene que viajar muchísimo mejor que le
eche un vistazo a su estatus de vuelo
Porque muchos han sido cancelados muchos
han sido retrasados porque no hay forma
de llegar al destino sobre todo si va
hacia los grandes lagos y va hacia
porciones de nordeste del país Nueva
York Boston donde todavía las
condiciones se mantienen bastante
peligrosas y más allá de ir en avión
Pues tampoco se recomienda ir en
carreteras porque prácticamente se hace
imposible manejar en algunas vías donde
incluso han sido cerrados por el
Departamento de transporte